[Music]
let's just go to kate in denver and get
this show going america i'm alive let's
go to kate what's up kate
hi hi how are you i'm good how are you
it's been it's been a morning it's been
a morning
sounds like it but
[Laughter]
uh i can hear the sympathy in your voice
thank you for for loving me so much kate
so what's up i'm glad you're okay thank
you what's up
so my husband and i we have two boys
they're nine and seven um
my husband's side of the family is very
my husband and the side of his family
are very they're very obese
my side of the family and myself are not
i'm very active
um how
how do i safely and carefully teach
the boys about weight and
healthy habits
oh that's such a great question
um a couple let me ask you a couple
questions how long have i been married
i'm going on 12 years 12 years all right
is your husband obese
yes tell me about that
um the whole family is they've all
struggled
with weight
a couple of his siblings have managed to
lose weight but i you know i don't i
don't know what it's like
fortunately i guess
they will lose the weight
but then it kind of just comes back you
know it's hard hard to keep off i'm sure
when it's a family thing
um
yes and and no um
so
there's going to be some genetic
predisposition there there's no question
about that and there's also going to be
some
tendencies some just natural
inclinations
but there's gonna be a big chunk of this
is gonna be model behavior this is how
we live this is how we eat this is who
we are this is what we do for fun this
is what we do for stress this is what we
do for hurt or pain etc right
um you may have heard me say on this
show i was surprised yet not surprised
um i had a bunch of genetic work done
earlier this year and they told me i you
know i have something called the
cookie jar jean
and i was like what is that and he said
it's not deterministic but you have a
leaning that when you get stressed you
get exhausted if you see an open package
of x y or z
you will finish that package and so
discipline for you is less about white
knuckling it through things
it's more about you can never have that
in your house right so it's a genetic
it's a it's a leaning but there's some
behavior there right there's some
activity and action there
so here's the hard thing um again i'm
not a medical doctor
and i'm also not a
geneticist so i would recommend that you
get some genetic testing done on your
boys and on you and on your husband have
y'all met with a doctor before
not about this okay hell
um if you'll stay on the line when we
get done i'll give you the name to my
doctor um and he incorporates all
everything from your genetics to your
blood work to everything into hey here's
how you can change your life in a very
sp specific way
um here's what's gonna be hard for your
boys is that
they're watching everything
and so they are absorbing and learning
this stuff and so true behavior change
are they already showing signs of being
overweight
no they're very very skinny but my
husband said that he was very tiny like
that too and
they they do see a big difference
because
i i teach fitness classes i run
marathons and they see me and then they
see
their dad and i just don't know
i don't know how to
teach them safely
you can
so take take the family stuff off
obviously you and your husband have had
conversations about this this has
impacted your relationship in some way
tell me about that
um
yeah mostly just because i worry about
what the boys see and i don't i don't
want them to
think that having
extra weight is a bad thing it's not
it's you know as long as you're healthy
that's what matters
and i want them to not feel like
they can't do something because they
have extra weight or they may have extra
weight and see i don't even know
which direction they're going to go
they're still
fairly young right
um what is it about
does your husband struggle
does he enjoy
his his body i mean does he enjoy is he
unable to do certain things when you say
obese is he 30 pounds overweight or is
he 130 pounds overweight he's probably
about 150 pounds overweight okay does he
struggle to get around is it something
he
would love to change what what is it
about his situation that is keeping him
stuck
um he
no he's not happy with his weight he
does want to lose it he's a stress eater
um and his job is obviously very
stressful
um so he
stress eats and then he
you know he's tired of having a hard
time finding the right pair of jeans
um
we have the boys and i and my husband we
have dirt bikes and we love to go ride
and he struggles he can keep up you know
he's very active
um as far as
his job mechanicing like he doesn't sit
around and do nothing
he's physically active he just doesn't
he has a hard time keeping up sometimes
with the boys if they want to play
sports if we want to go for walks or
bike ride does he crash when he gets
home
yes
just hits the couch
yeah he'll hit the couch he he naps
you know with well if he sits around for
a while which i sometimes do too you
know you sit around you get tired sure
i'll take a nap yeah
so um
here's the thing
your boys are gonna
absorb the quote unquote
way we do things or the way things are
done
through
models
through pictures
and they will learn how to be a dad by
watching their dad
and they will learn how to be a mom by
watching their mom or what moms quote
unquote do
and so
if you are worried about my boy's
downstream behavior
then the number one thing you can do is
model different behavior
and that means
that you and your husband need to have a
hard conversation that starts something
like
you're 150 pounds overweight and i'm
afraid you're gonna die
are you worried about him
i am he's we're in our
early 30s um
he's been on
medication for pre-diabetes um yeah
so
it's yeah it's very worse recently my
grandma died of diabetes though so
you've seen this you're watching it
there's going to be some some genetic
predispositions there
my guess is underneath
because at some point someone has to
decide this is what my life is worth
and the folks that i've met with and
again i'm not i don't specialize in this
sort of eating that's its own world and
it's notorious for how challenging it is
but with those that i've met with over
the years
the conversation always lends itself to
this is just the way it is
this is just the way i am or
no of course i don't want to do that but
i can't there's this limiting
script there's this limiting story that
they've seen they've been told they've
been they've they've had modeled for
them
and
often these are the most extraordinary
people and they are lovely and hilarious
they have they've got a great person and
they've got to adapt right
and at some the ones that make the big
change are the ones that get to the
place where they say
my life is worth feeling good
the hard that it's going to take to lose
this weight
to just
flip that switch and say today's the day
i start exercising today's the day i get
a less stressful job if i have to
today's the day i take six months off of
work and we scrimp and and claw and
scratch financially so i can get my soul
back and get my marriage back so i can
be a good picture for these kids the
words that keep coming to mind here are
change your family tree
and
i would be willing to bet if you've got
a family legacy of this there's some
sort of something going on there and who
knows what it is right did he have a
hard childhood
no no straight forward
okay
that's fantastic so um
ultimately it's him deciding i want to
live a different life
and
one of the greatest gifts you could give
those little boys
is a dad who says i'm going to do
something different
can i tell you mine on a much smaller
much more minor scale
um i'm late everywhere and i am a wreck
like i just i'm always carrying stuff
everywhere literally i got in a wreck
today not paying attention i don't pay
attention very well i'm usually thinking
about something or
crafting i always my heads are in the
clouds a lot
and
i went into my son's room about six or
seven months ago and it looked like he
had just taken everything in his drawers
and dumped it out and i realized he
hadn't done that this is just how he was
living and more importantly i walked
back into my room to tell my wife like
we got to do something about that and i
looked at my side of the room and i was
i just had this moment of oh no
like this isn't a matter of my son
lacking character integrity or whatever
he's just being just like his old man
and i sat my son down we actually
actually took him out and i said hey i
have to make some life changes
and i want you to come along with me
and the two big life changes are going
to be about being on time because it's
disrespectful to you to your mother and
to your sister and to our family into
our church community when i walk in
there 15 minutes late to my people i
work with
um and
i haven't done a good job so all to say
is i laid it out and i'm gonna become
militant about having a clean home
and that starts with me and you're gonna
know i need you to know i'm gonna turn
the tables on you in a way that i've
never done before and i've kept up my
end of the bargain
and interestingly he's followed along
and it's been great he does push back
like i don't want to make my bid i like
sleeping in a huge pile of way right but
he's it started with me sitting down
with him and saying i need to do things
differently and you can watch me and
you're coming along for the ride and
then in your world it's a total we're
going to shop differently we're going to
act differently we're going to deal with
stress differently we're going to work
differently we're going to communicate
with each other differently
probably need to get some mental health
professional to walk alongside him a
hundred percent should get a medical
professional with him and there's
something different when you go to a
medical professional and say
i want to lose some weight
um or i need my you know i got to get my
diabetes under control or i'm
pre-diabetic metabolic syndrome any of
those things
there's something different when you go
to your doctor and say i'm done today is
the day we change everything and i need
you to walk alongside me um the doctor i
use is named dr gus vicary and he's out
of north carolina and he does a lot of
his work um
i don't even know if he's taking new
patients right now i just put us just
put him on blast but he does a lot of
his work um
mobile right um over the internet we
communicate back and forth and he's one
of the greatest men i've ever met and
one of the greatest scholar researchers
and he's brilliant
um and he takes everything into account
and it's also very expensive like i
don't want to i don't want to mention
any i don't want to give people the
wrong impression it's very very
expensive to have that level of
attention and detail what i would tell
you all is
150 pounds overweight early 30s young
boys
the money's worth it if you can find it
if you've got it you can scratch and
claw and if you don't have that money
which is totally understandable because
it's expensive
um
go to your doctor and say i need help
i'm ready go find a psychologist or a
counselor in your area and say it's time
we're gonna do the things to change
behaviors to change the way we think i'm
gonna look in the mirror and say you are
worth
not having backaches you're worth riding
your motorcycles with the kids you're
worth changing your family tree somebody
has to stare down that forest fire and
say no no more
okay that's that's what it's going to
come down to is modeling different
behavior and then being highly
intentional about teaching your kids the
right way to eat they're going to move
their body the right way to deal with
stress the right way to deal with hurt
the right way to do with pain
but that's going to start with new
pictures and new models